[Musique]
bon soit alexis poulain merci de
répondre à nos questions directes sur rt
france évasion et optimisation fiscale
visiblement un problème français
oui alors ils sont effectivement plus
nombreux que les italiens et les
allemands réunis plus nombreux aussi que
les luxembourgeois
quinze mille français qui ont logé 100
milliards d'actifs au luxembourg c'est
4% du pib français on retrouve bien sûr
bnp paribas et vmh gearing et 37 des 50
plus grandes fortunes françaises dont
bernard arnault alors pourquoi sont ils
aussi nombreux les français au
luxembourg est ce qu'il ya un petit
problème peut-être de fiscalité en
france ou bien est ce que on échappe à
l'impôt et c'est plus facile en cachant
c'est son argent au luxembourg je veux
savoir qu'en france pour constituer son
budget l'état environ 300 milliards
d'euros doit trouver des ressources et
90% des ressources et bien c'est l'impôt
des personnes et et des sociétés et la
france a toujours été et inventive en
matière d'impôts c'est bien tva impôts
directs impôt indirect crds cg
cotisations sociales impôts sur les
sociétés fiscalité du patrimoine etc etc
ça en fait beaucoup ce qui fait que la
france est le deuxième pays avec le plus
fort taux d'imposition dans l' ocde
derrière le danemark
alors il ya beaucoup effectivement
d'impôts il y avait même un rapport de
l'inspection générale des finances qui
disait qu'il y avait environ 190 taxe
qui ne rapportaient que 150 millions
d'euros par an donc il y a du travail à
faire effectivement pour que cette
redistribution fonctionne et que l'impôt
soit efficace en france alors l'ars
tribus et la redistribution en panne que
se passe-t-il alexis
alors la france dépense 50 3% de son pib
dans les dépenses publiques 30% pour les
transferts justement et 23% pour la
fourniture des biens et des services
publics
seulement voilà on a l'impression qu'il
ya de plus en plus de français qui
tombent dans la précarité des millions
qui ont recours aux banques alimentaires
et des services publics qui sont
défectueux alors où va l'argent on peut
se le demander
il ya trois principaux postes de
dépenses publiques il ya la retraite
bien entendu
l'assurance maladie et l'éducation
nationale à eux trois ils représentent
55 % de la dépense publique mais il ya
aussi le financement des autres
prestations sociales l'assurance-maladie
l'aide au logement les allocations
familiales etc
et puis les remboursement des intérêts
de la dette
alors la question de francs évidemment
faut-il en définitive revoir l'assiette
des impôts et la fiscalité dans notre
pays alors c'est une question qui se
pose souvent
effectivement la france a fait le choix
d'un système redistributif pour limiter
les inégalités mais il ya beaucoup
d'améliorations l'impôt sur le revenu en
france ne représentent que 7% dû total
des impôts et des taxes
en fait il ya plus de la moitié des
français 56% qui ne payent pas d'impôt
sur le revenu il ya un barème progressif
en fait plus on gagne d'argent plus on a
un taux d'imposition élevé l'idée c'est
que au delà de cent cinquante six mille
euros vous êtes taxé à 45 % l'impôt sur
le revenu et au delà de soixante treize
mille euros à 41 %
l'idée c'est que les 20% les plus riches
vont perdre un cinquième en fait en
termes de qualité de vie tandis que les
30 40 % les plus pauvres eux vont gagner
c'est 20% et avoir un meilleur une
meilleure qualité de vie mais il ya
d'autre systèmes possibles
on pourrait avoir des taxes plus
partagés à singapour par exemple
c'est 12% d'imposition pour tout le
monde vous avez aussi la fameuse taxe
sur les transactions financières la ttf
qui n'a jamais vu le jour et qui
pourtant pourrait rapporter beaucoup
d'argent et puis une micro taxe sur les
transactions électroniques que l'on fait
en carte bleue et qui pourrait rapporter
à 0 0 1% ou 0 001 % des milliards qui
manquent cruellement aux caisses de
l'état et aux caisses européennes
alors il ya ça le problème des recettes
mais aussi le problème des dépenses
parce qu'en france on en parlait dans la
passe tir avant il y à une fraude
aux prestations sociales il ya eu un
rapport de la cour des comptes
effectivement en 2019 qui disait qu' il
ya un milliard de préjudice en fait
qu'ils sont perdus dans la nature parce
qu'il ya très peu de contrôles et un
rapport parlementaire de 2020 qui a
quand même fait état de 5.4 millions de
cartes vitale qui en fait n'ont pas de
propriétaire il ya plus de capital que
de français donc c'est même une petite
question qui se pose est quand on lit
les deux rapports et bien on se rend
compte que c'est entre 14 et 50
milliards en fait de fraude aux
prestations sociales qu'il y aurait en
france donc problème de redistribution
paradis fiscal au coeur de l'europe les
français voient bien que quelque chose
ne va pas est ce qu'un candidat
courageux va porter une réforme fiscale
de fonds pour 2022 ça ça reste à voir
et la question à qui peut-on alors
régler la problématique fiscale au
niveau européen défaut de le faire en
france
comme vous y allez stéphanie au niveau
européen quand même on a le luxembourg
la belgique les pays bas qui sont des
membres fondateurs et qui sont des
paradis fiscaux un des facto et puis
l'irlande malte le portugal donc ça fait
beaucoup de pays membres qui n'ont aucun
intérêt à revoir
en fait la façon dont ils donnent de
l'argent elle fit secret de polichinelle
le luxembourg il y avait les loques
slicks déjà scandale financier suite
avec un lanceur d' alerte qui avait
alerté à l'époque
donc on le savait que le luxembourg
était un paradis fiscal et jean claude
juncker l'ex premier ministre
luxembourgeois a été remercié en
devenant le président de la commission
européenne en 2014
en fait les dés sont pipés en europe la
façon dont s'organisent les débats font
que les européens doivent voter à la
majorité pour changer les règles
financières c'est l'article 113 du
traité de fonctionnement de l'union
européenne qui fait que rien ne change
jamais puisque aucun des membres de
l'union européenne ne va se tirer une
balle dans le pied
et pourtant dans ce traité du
fonctionnement de l'union européenne il
ya l'article 116 qui permet de lutter
contre la distorsion de concurrence est
là figurez vous que les activités
financières ne sont pas exonérés de
cette concurrence
or rien n'est jamais fait c'est plus
facile effectivement pour l'union
européenne de demander à la france par
exemple de démanteler à champion de
l'énergie comme edf que de demander au
luxembourg de revoir ses règles fiscales
alors il ya quand même le commissaire
européen actuel qui s'appelle paolo
gentiloni qui a proposé de rire
le code de conduite la façon dont se
gèrent les affaires financières au
niveau européen
ce que pierre moscovici n'avait pas
réussi à faire pour rendre compte de
nouvelles pratiques et lui il promet des
propositions européennes en 2021 pour
avoir une imposition minimale pour
revoir les règles de résidence fiscale
et pour rendre compte des nouvelles
pratiques pour éviter ce dumping fiscal
au sein même de l'union européenne
c'est en réalité 824 milliards d'euros
qui sont qui échappent en fait à l'impôt
et aux recettes pour les états membres
pour la france ça se monterait à 118
milliards c'est une étude de
l'université de londres de richard
murphy qu'étaient publiés en 2019 qui
fait état de ces chiffres donc on peut
voir que ça risque d'avancer très
lentement au niveau européen pour revoir
les règles fiscales jeu j'en fais le
pari même en 2021
les avancées seront malheureusement
minimes en la matière elle vous m'avez
donné elle a mal à la tête avec ses
règles fiscales avec steeve poulin merci
à vous et dites les lifts merci à vous